I'm gonna tell you why my perception of
lacking fear is so real it's because I
fear something so much I fear the health
and well-being of my family so much and
I mean crippled by it hence why you're a
grown-ass man and you get up during a
vacation and go to some weird corner and
pray for your mom to wake up you know
I'm so fearful of the well-being of the
ten to fifteen people in my life
it is so disproportionately the most
important thing to me in the world that
it just makes everything else so easy
you know the thought of losing all my
money is so weirdly exciting because I
know I have the talent to rise back up
as a phoenix it's interesting I thought
that would go away when I had the kids
and it has the Sun free um but not
really and I think then that's how it
plays out on the gang right which is I
I'm so into my feelings I dream up find
the Jets or having somebody say this is
the visit this was guys they he was the
best entrepreneur of this generation and
and then I think about that being
anointed on me and then getting a phone
call and hearing that my mom died in the
car accident I do this to myself and
then I see how I feel and since I feel
awful
well then why in the world would I get
caught so up in the financial or other
things
there's vulnerability where I'm aware of
but boy I'm super not scared when it
comes to business
first of all I've been doing it my whole
life I've always been good at it I'm
good but it's because I'm so scared of
something else